Revisore: Cristina Bufi-Pöcksteiner
Questa corda mi ha salvato la vita.
Ero a circa
6.000 metri sul Nanga Parbat,
questa montagna altissima
di 8.125 metri,
che si trova in Pakistan.
Stavo scalando,
quando, in pieno inverno,
a quelle altitudini,
un ancoraggio ha ceduto
e sono caduto nel vuoto.
Vedete, oggi sono qui a raccontarvi
questa storia,
proprio perché
una corda molto simile a questa
ha tenuto il mio volo.
E quindi posso raccontarvi la mia storia
su questa montagna incredibile,
dove sono stato per ben
4 anni.
Ero sulla via Kinshofer, in questo
versante gigantesco della montagna,
in inverno,
a 30, 40, 50 gradi sotto zero.
Ma il mio sogno in realtà non era salire
la via Kinshofer, ma riuscire a risalire
al centro di questa montagna,
all'inviolato sperone Mummery.
Uno sperone fatto
di pareti rocciose, di pareti di ghiaccio.
Una via elegante, diretta e stupefacente,
che sale quasi come una spada
in vetta al Nanga Parbat.
Vedete,
affrontare uno sperone inviolato
vuol dire non soltanto essere preparati
tecnicamente
e fisicamente,
ma vuol dire anche
avere il coraggio
di affrontare l'ignoto,
cioè ciò che non si conosce.
Su montagne di questo tipo,
affrontare l'ignoto vuol dire proprio
avere il coraggio
di sopportare quella pressione
che ti fanno i luoghi
che non sono mai stati calpestati.
Questa zona della montagna è stata
la meta di un grandissimo sognatore,
Albert Frederick Mummery.
Immaginate.
Nel 1895 quest'uomo,
60 anni prima che una montagna
di 8.000 metri fosse scalata,
parte dall'Europa e ha il coraggio
di affrontare mesi di viaggio per arrivare
in Pakistan
e poi ai piedi di questa montagna.
E per primo individua questo sperone,
che dalla vetta scende
fino alla base della montagna.
Mummery fu un uomo
così coraggioso --per il quale--
questo tentativo che lui fece
di arrivare alla montagna,
passò alla storia.
Fu riconosciuto come il primo che ebbe
il coraggio di affrontare queste montagne
con mezzi leali,
con le proprie forze
e le forze dei suoi compagni.
Senza mezzi artificiali,
senza corde fisse, senza portatori,
senza ossigeno.
E da quel momento
fu individuato come colui
che mise le basi dello stile alpino.
Questo stile che prevede
la scalata di queste montagne
in velocità
e con poca attrezzatura.
Uno stile molto puro
di scalare le montagne.
Vedete,
A un certo punto,
mi sono ritrovato a 5.700 metri.
Ho scalato questo sperone
ben due volte,
una volta in compagnia
e una volta in solitaria.
Quella volta ero da solo,
ero nella tenda
e affascinato da questa storia incredibile
di Albert Frederick Mummery,
a un certo punto ho percepito,
come se fosse vero,
fuori dalla tenda,
con lo sperone sopra di me,
con le mie paure --ero lì da solo--
È come se avessi percepito realmente
la presenza di quest'uomo,
che faceva scricchiolare la neve
e quasi mi accompagnava,
nel desiderio
di
ripercorrere le sue orme, ma continuare
ed andare su.
Ho scalato lo sperone,
però non sono riuscito
ad arrivare su quel plateau finale,
per poi arrivare in vetta, ma--
Veramente,
qui c'è il vero motivo
di essere andato in inverno
al Nanga Parbat.
Il fatto di poter onorare
quella figura audace
di Albert Frederick Mummery
e usare lo stile alpino,
in inverno, su una via nuova,
per cercare di fare,
anche da solo,
ciò che non era mai stato fatto
nella storia dell'alpinismo.
A quel punto però, sceso dallo sperone,
una sfida incredibile e difficilissima--
Decido di cambiare rotta
e di tornare sulla via Kinshofer.
La via Kinshofer è una via percorsa
d'estate più di 300 volte
da tanti alpinisti di tutto il mondo,
tra cui
anche la mia scalata,
che avvenne nel 2008,
ma in piena estate.
Nessuno è mai riuscito
a scalare lo sperone Mummery
in inverno, né tantomeno in estate.
Ma la via Kinshofer invece è una via
che è stata percorsa tante volte
ed è il motivo per cui
ci sono alcune agevolazioni,
facilitazioni, sulla montagna,
perché gli alpinisti a forza di salire
e scendere dalla montagna
lasciano degli ancoraggi sulla parete,
ed alcune corde,
tra le quali anche quella che,
come vi dicevo all'inizio di questo racconto,
ha ceduto
e mi ha lasciato cadere nel vuoto.
Vedete,
al primo tentativo
sulla via Kinshofer, in realtà, arrivo
molto vicino alla vetta della montagna,
circa 7.800 metri,
solo 300 metri dalla vetta.
A quel punto, uno dei miei due compagni
ha degli evidenti sintomi
del male acuto di montagna.
Un male che nell'arco di pochi minuti
ti fa morire.
E in quel momento senza nessun dubbio
abbiamo deciso di scendere dalla montagna
e quindi andare verso il campo
base e fermarci lì.
Vedete, in quel momento ho capito
una cosa
molto importante.
Abbiamo provato a fare questo volo,
verso la vetta della montagna,
ma a volte succede che la brama
di arrivare in vetta, oppure il desiderio
di salire sempre più in alto
può essere così
incantatore, che può
farci dimenticare
quali sono i veri valori della vita,
la vita stessa.
Sapete,
io scalo da una vita,
sin da quando ero bambino,
e vivo a Latina, in pianura Pontina.
E potete immaginare
che le montagne lì, proprio
non sono il paesaggio naturale.
Pensate che,
quando ho detto a degli amici
che avrei voluto scalare
a 8.000 metri,
si son messi a sorridere,
eppure,
partendo dai miei monti di 1.500 metri
ho avuto la forza e il coraggio di salire
le Dolomiti, sulle Alpi,
e poi ancora affrontare le montagne
di 8.000 metri della Terra,
quelle più alte, più affascinanti.
Eppure in questo percorso
ho fatto tanti voli,
non solo quelli sul Nanga Parbat.
E mi sono accorto
che, a volte, i voli
non sono solo il fatto
di cadere dalla montagna
e avere un pezzo di corda
che trattiene il tuo volo.
Ma può voler dire anche
avere il coraggio di affrontare le sfide,
di fare un passo in là,
dove magari c'è quella linea di ignoto
dove possiamo
andare a conoscere qualcosa
di diverso.
E ritornando sempre a questa corda,
c'è stato un momento,
proprio nell'inverno scorso,
quando c'è stato anche il primo volo--
In realtà ero lì sulla montagna
a scalare, a cercare di fissare queste corde
non in stile alpino,
ma con uno stile classico
con un alpinista incredibile,
un polacco, Adam Bialeti.
A un certo punto
anche lui, mentre fissa un ancoraggio
sulla parete, scivola
e cade verso il basso,
metro dopo metro, per 80 metri.
Ero lì,
sulla parete,
con un solo ancoraggio fra me e lui.
Potevo scegliere,
per una questione razionale,
o di sopravvivenza,
di sganciare la corda dal mio imbrago
e lasciarlo cadere,
giù, verso il basso,
oppure, magari bloccare la sua corda,
su quell'ancoraggio lì.
Perché a volte gli alpinisti
fanno un tacito accordo.
È quasi preferibile
che vada via uno solo,
piuttosto che entrambi.
Ma io ed Adam non eravamo così,
non siamo così.
Abbiamo scelto di fare una scalata
insieme, di legare quel nodo
e di salire insieme.
Ho tenuto l'ancoraggio.
Lui ha dato un urto molto violento
sulla mia corda, ma il mio peso
ha ammortizzato questo urto.
E sbattendo sulla parete
l'ancoraggio ha tenuto,
e noi siamo sopravvissuti.
Lui oggi è dai suoi figli
e io sono potuto tornare a casa.
Ho imparato
veramente tanto
dalla montagna.
Ma dopo tutti questi incidenti,
e scelte che possono far differenza,
se tenere una corda,
oppure lasciare
e andar via alle prime difficoltà,
o a qualsiasi difficoltà
che si incontra,
mi son chiesto in profondità
che senso avesse per me
continuare a scalare le montagne
e andare sempre più in alto,
ad affrontare tutte le difficoltà
che ci sono.
In fondo,
all'epoca di Mummery nel 1895,
quando lui, tra l'altro,
non fece ritorno dalla spedizione,
l'obiettivo primario dell'alpinismo
era semplicemente vedere se l'uomo
fosse in grado veramente di arrivare
sulle alte vette.
Una volta che queste erano state salite
e quindi che l'uomo aveva dimostrato
che poteva andare lì su,
in realtà l'alpinismo
si è spostato
su un altro campo,
cioè sulla qualità della salita,
la capacità di utilizzare uno stile veloce,
su pareti sempre più difficili.
Ma adesso qual è il significato,
a questo punto
di affrontare queste montagne,
soprattutto quando
su in alta quota
si è come dentro un congelatore.
Il vento ci sferza
e siamo lontani dalle comodità
che abbiamo giornalmente a casa.
E soprattutto, quando scaliamo
in alta quota, sappiamo per certo
che quando superiamo
i 7.000-8.000 metri,
in realtà cominciamo a morire
un po' alla volta.
E se io prendessi uno di voi e lo portassi
veramente, in uno schioccar di dita,
a 8.000 metri,
morirebbe di asfissia
nell'arco di pochi minuti.
Noi alpinisti possiamo
essere qui, perché saliamo e scendiamo
dalla montagna più volte
proprio per far sì che il nostro corpo
si adatti all'alta quota
e quindi che i globuli rossi aumentino.
E possiamo fare questa attività
sportiva.
Però capite bene che siamo molto lontani
dalla situazione normale di agiatezza
che possiamo avere nella società.
Io credo
che l'alpinismo
sia un mezzo incredibile,
lontano dai condizionamenti,
sociali e civili,
di affrontare un argomento
che è sempre molto ostico.
Quello, in qualche modo,
di scendere dentro noi stessi
e dentro la natura dell'uomo
e cercare di capire se effettivamente
siamo fatti solo di carne, ossa, neuroni
e molecole.
Oppure se dentro di noi c'è
una forza vitale,
se siamo fatti di una forza vitale,
che ci permette di decidere, a volte,
se rimanere in cordata
con i nostri amici,
se continuare a sfidare la vita,
a perseverare,
oppure se abbandonare
a qualsiasi difficoltà.
A quel punto,
credo che
c'è una magia nella scalata.
Vedete,
su questo capo di corda,
a un lato di questo capo,
ci sono legato io,
potrebbe esserci legato uno di voi.
Però,
non è finita qui.
All'altro capo c'è una donna o un uomo,
che hanno deciso di legarsi
alla vostra corda.
Vedete, ogni
volta che si vola,
questa corda potrebbe fare ben poco,
se non ci fosse all'altro capo
qualcuno,
che abbia deciso di tenere quella corda
e quindi trattenere il vostro volo.
E
Io credo che, in 22 anni di alpinismo
estremo, fra le tante cose che ho imparato
ce ne sono due in particolare
che
sento mie.
La prima è che, secondo me, l'uomo
ha proprio questa forza vitale.
Forse è una forza vitale
con la quale riesce
ad affrontare le difficoltà,
anche quando queste difficoltà
sembrano insuperabili.
D'altro canto, però,
bisogna stare veramente attenti
a scegliere quelle persone
che all'altro capo della corda
decideranno di rimanere
in cordata con noi.
E continuare a perseverare,
fino a superare le difficoltà.
Credo che questa sia una lezione
che avrei potuto comprendere
sin da bambino.
Se ci pensate, quando noi nasciamo,
in qualche modo
voliamo nella vita,
cerchiamo di decollare.
E c'è qualcuno che sorregge i nostri voli
e in qualche maniera ci fa sicurezza.
Solo che spesso, man mano
che cresciamo, che andiamo verso la vita,
non ci rendiamo conto esattamente
di questa cosa.
A me c'è voluto un po' per impararla.
Però devo ammettere,
e lo dico con un po' d'ironia,
che se fossi stato
un pochettino più sveglio,
forse lo avrei potuto capire
molto prima di passare
quattro inverni interi della mia vita
a prender freddo al Nanga Parbat.
Grazie.
(Applausi)